hallo deutsch schule deutsch lernen mit
reimen
was reimt sich auf
haus
die maus die
maus
der applaus der applaus
der
nikolaus der nikolaus
in washington befindet sich das weiße
haus
in washington
befindet sich das weiße haus am
computer benutze ich mit der rechten
hand die maus am computer benutze ich
mit der rechten hand die maus
für den vortrag bekommt der redner ein
applaus für den vortrag bekommt der
redner ein
applaus
jedes jahr am sechsten dezember
kommt der nikolaus
kennst du die nikolaus tradition in
deutschland
was reimt sich auf hose die dose die
dose die rose die rose
der matrose der
matrose
wenn ich joggen gehe trage ich immer
eine kurze hose wenn ich joggen gehe
trage ich immer eine kurze hose am
liebsten trinke ich eine cola aus der
dose am liebsten trinke ich eine cola
aus der dose
zum hochzeitstag schenke ich meiner frau
jedes jahr eine rose zum hochzeitstag
schenke ich meiner frau
jedes jahr eine rose
der matrose
arbeitet auf einem schiff der matrose
arbeitet auf einem schiff
hast du schon mal eine reise mit dem
schiff gemacht
was reimt sich auf geld die welt
die welt
das zählt das zählt der held der held
in deutschland kann man überall mit
bargeld bezahlen in deutschland kann man
überall mit bargeld bezahlen
in zukunft werden acht milliarden
menschen auf der welt leben in
zukunft werden acht milliarden menschen
auf der welt leben
unser
campingurlaub mit unserem neuen zelt war
so schön
unser
campingurlaub mit unserem neuen zelt war
so schön
mister super deutsch schnee wir brauchen
deine hilfe
mister super deutsch schnell wir
brauchen deine hilfe
na klar
kein problem
mister super deutsch hilft euch beim
deutsch lernen na klar kein problem
deutsch lernen
welche superhelden findest du am besten
was reimt sich auf t
der kaffee der kaffee
das café
der schnee
am morgen
brauche ich erstmal eine heiße tasse
kaffee am morgen
kaffee
hallo ich bin team willkommen in meinem
café
in meinem kaffee
trinken die leute entweder tee oder
kaffee in meinem kaffee
kaffee am liebsten trinke ich abends auf
der arbeit eine tasse tee am
liebsten trinke ich abends auf der
arbeit eine tasse tee
juhu endlich
gibt es wieder schnee zum skifahren
fährst du lieber ski oder
snowboard was reimt sich auf hunt der
mund der mund
bund
rund
ich gehe jeden tag mindestens
einmal mit meinem hund spazieren
ich gehe jeden tag mindestens einmal mit
meinem hund spazieren
wenn ich die deutsche aussprache über
dann beobachte ich mein mund vor dem
spiegel
wenn ich die deutsche aussprache über
dann beobachte ich mein mund vor dem
spiegel
heute trage ich ein outfit mit vielen
farben ich trage ein buntes outfit
das viereck ist eckig und der kreis ist
rund
rund was
reimt sich auf schuh
die kuh
das tattoo
das kanu
das kanu im schuhgeschäft
gibt es viele schuhe in
verschiedenen schuhgrößen im
schuhgeschäft
gibt es viele schuhe in
verschiedenen schuhgrößen die kuh steht
auf der wiese und frisst grünes gras
die kuh
steht auf der wiese und frisst grünes
gras
hey mama wie findest du mein neues
tattoo
ist das cool ich kaufe mir heute gleich
ein kanu
[Musik]
ist das cool ich kaufe mir heute gleich
ein kanu
bist du auch schon mal mit einem kanu
gefahren
was reimt sich auf hunt der strand der
strand der diamant der diamant
der elefant
ich halte jeden tag viele stunden mein
smartphone in der hand
smartphone in der hand der hochzeitsring
meiner frau ist ein edler diamant der
hochzeitsring meiner frau ist ein edler
diamant im sommer wackelt der elefant
mit den ohren um kühle luft zu
produzieren
im sommer wackelt der elefant mit den
ohren um kühle luft zu produzieren
was ist dein lieblingstier
was reimt sich auf bier
das klavier
der stier
der stier das papier
das papier
auf dem oktoberfest in münchen
trinke ich ein leckeres bier
johannis lernt die neunte sinfonie
von beethoven auf dem klavier johannes
lernt die neunte sinfonie von beethoven
auf dem klavier
der wilde stiere rennt wie verrückt auf
das rote tuch zu der wilde stier rennt
wie verrückt auf das rote tuch zu
ich schreibe meine notizen im
deutschunterricht
auf ein blatt papier
ich schreibe meine notizen im
deutschunterricht
auf ein blatt papier
machst du auch notizen im
deutschunterricht
was reimt sich auf stein der wein
der wein
das bein
das design
das design für einen echten superhelden
ist kein stein zu schwer für einen
echten superhelden ist kein stein zu
schwer zum abendessen
trinken wir immer gerne ein gläschen
rotwein
zum abendessen
trinken wir immer gerne ein gläschen
rotwein
ich schieße den fußball mit dem bein
nach vorne
das design von diesem bild gefällt mir
ausgesprochen gut
ist design für dich wichtig
was reimt sich auf bett
das ballett das ballett
das brett das brett
das omelett
ich schlafe jede nacht neun stunden in
meinem gemütlichen bett ich schlafe jede
nacht neun stunden in meinem gemütlichen
bett beim ballett
benötigt man eine extrem gute
körperspannung beim ballett
körperspannung
unsere neue bank im garten
besteht aus vier brettern
besteht aus vier brettern heute mache
ich zum frühstück ein leckeres am leck
mit sechs eiern
heute mache ich zum frühstück ein
leckeres omelett mit sechs eiern
ist du gerne eier zum frühstück
was reimt sich auf kino der dino
der dino das casino das casino
der cappuccino der cappuccino ich kaufe
die karten fürs kino an der kinokasse
ich kaufe die karten fürs kino an der
kinokasse
im kino läuft ein film über einen
gefährlichen dino im kino läuft ein film
über einen gefährlichen dino
im casino spielen viele verschiedene
leute poker im casino spielen viele
verschiedene leute poker guten tag ich
hätte gerne ein cappuccino bitte guten
tag ich hätte gerne einen cappuccino
bitte trinkst du auch gerne ein
cappuccino
abonniere den kanal der halle deutsch
schule und aktiviere das kleine
glöckchen gib uns jetzt einen daumen
nach oben und klicke auf diese playlist
für weitere videos zum deutsch lernen